Новини дня «heute» з Мітрієм Сіріним.
Добрий вечір, ми підготували для Вас
найголовніші новини цієї неділі.
Про спорт сьогодні розповість Норберт Кеніг.
Погляньмо на теми сьогоднішнього випуску.
Плани посилення
антимонопольного законодавства -
міністр економіки Габек вживатиме суворіших
заходів проти нафтових концернів,
тому що вони не надають
повноцінних знижок на пальне для споживачів.
Парламентські вибори у Франції -
для президента Макрона є підстави непокоїтися -
чи отримає його союз абсолютну більшість
голосів на Національних зборах.
Перемога команди «Red Bull» -
чемпіон світу Макс Ферстаппен
посів перше місце на Гран-прі Азербайджану.
Усе відбулося швидко.
Питання, яке спричиняє
сьогодні найбільший резонанс,
а саме дискусійна знижка на пальне,
посилює суперечки у політичних колах.
Зазнавши вчора критики від
представників опозиційної партії CDU,
які закликають нарешті почати діяти,
міністр економіки Габек
тепер планує посилити
антимонопольне законодавство
щодо нафтових концернів.
За найгіршим сценарієм, на підприємства
може чекати навіть примусове закриття.
Подробиці розповість Ян Фріче.
Останнім часом критика на адресу
міністра економіки Габека лунає щораз гучніше:
мовляв, необхідно вжити суворіших заходів
щодо нафтових компаній.
Сьогодні міністр відреагував на ці заклики.
На тому, що впроваджувалося як підтримка
для громадян і споживачів,
тепер наживаються великі нафтові концерни.
Цілком зрозуміло, що так не має бути
і що це спричинює
загальне невдоволення й обурення.
Саме тому тепер Габек планує
посилити антимонопольне законодавство:
навіть якщо немає
прямих доказів «картельної змови»,
антимонопольний комітет може
вживати жорстких заходів,
наприклад, конфіскувати прибутки концерну
або в крайньому разі навіть ліквідувати компанії.
Загальнонімецький автомобільний клуб ADAC
схвалює ініціативу Габека,
адже замість обіцяної знижки
у розмірі 35 центів на бензин
і 17 центів на дизель
водіям пропонують набагато менше.
На бензин діє знижка приблизно 20 центів
порівняно з ціною до зниження податків.
На дизель знижки ще менші - всього 5 центів.
Тож споживачі не отримують повноцінної знижки.
Впровадження знижки на пальне
ініціювала партія FDP,
однак сьогодні ввечері її лідер не висловив
жодної критики щодо цього рішення,
натомість схвалив плани Габека, але знову висловився проти
податку на надприбуток.
Сподіваюся, пропозиція щодо цього
«податку на надприбуток» вже не розглядається,
адже це рішення спричинило б
хаос у податковому законодавстві,
а також хиткість політичних настроїв.
Нафтові концерни заперечують закиди Габека,
вказуючи на збільшення витрат на закупівлю нафти.
Плани міністра критикує й опозиція.
Втручання антимонопольного комітету
у випадку, коли не зафіксовано жодних порушень,
буде неможливим з перспективи закону.
У будь-якому разі найближчим часом плани Габека
не допоможуть громадянам
відчути фінансову підтримку в цінах на пальне.
Міністр економіки сподівається реалізувати
своє рішення ще цього року.
Тож суперечка навколо знижок на пальне триває.
Більше на цю тему, зокрема інтерв'ю
з міністром фінансів Лінднером,
Ви зможете побачити у випуску «Berlin direkt»
після нашого ефіру.
«Саме зараз, коли терпимість
до іншого способу життя та поглядів знижується,
соціальний обов'язок може стати особливо цінним» -
так висловився президент Німеччини Штайнмаєр в інтерв'ю
для газети «Bild am Sonntag», пропонуючи
запровадити обов'язкову соціальну службу для всієї молоді.
Міністерка у справах сім'ї Ліза Паус
відкидає цю пропозицію,
аргументуючи свою думку особистою свободою
кожної молодої людини.
Міністерка нагадала, що молодь особливо
сильно постраждала у період пандемії COVID-19.
Досі президент Франції Макрон міг ухвалювати
нові закони, покладаючись
на зручну для нього більшість у парламенті.
Однак після парламентських виборів
усе може змінитися.
Сьогодні відбувся перший тур.
За результатами останніх опитувань,
наразі триває напружена боротьба
з коаліцією лівих і зелених партій NUPES
і партією Жана-Люка Меланшона.
Останній об'єднався з соціалістами,
«зеленими» й комуністами
і тепер фігурує як потенційний прем'єрміністр.
З нами на зв'язку з Парижа Томас Вальде.
Томасе, яка наразі ситуація?
Передусім явка на цих виборах
була історично низькою.
За поточними прогнозами,
до кінця першого туру голосування
у виборах не візьме участь
навіть половина всіх виборців.
Молодь залишається вдома,
а старше покоління йде голосувати.
Останнє може бути на користь «макроністам».
Наразі вирішується питання,
скільки влади матиме Макрон
упродовж найближчих 5 років
і скільки реформ він зможе впровадити
завдяки підтримці парламенту,
як-от збільшення пенсійного віку
з 62 до 65 років.
Цьому й багатьом іншим планам
хоче запобігти новий лівий союз,
який сформувався перед виборами.
З мажоритарної системи виборів у Франції
користь можуть отримати ті,
хто об'єднується ще до виборів,
тому наразі очікують напружену боротьбу
між «макроністами» й лівими.
З 577 виборчих округів Франції, ймовірно,
у багатьох жоден з суперників не отримає абсолютної більшості.
Тому відбудеться другий тур виборів.
Точний результат і відповідь на запитання,
скільки влади матиме Макрон,
ми дізнаємося наступної неділі о 20:00.
Дякую, Томасе Вальде.
Після тривалого періоду пасивності
канцлер Німеччини Шольц,
ймовірно, все ж здійснить візит
в Україну цього місяця
разом з президентом Франції Макроном
і й очільником уряду Італії Драґі,
як повідомляє газета «Bild am Sonntag».
На Сході України тривають бої,
зокрема в Лисичанську.
Проросійські сили здійснювали напад
на об'єкти цивільної інфраструктури.
На Заході країни російські ракети
поцілили у військовий об'єкт.
За інформацією української сторони,
на Півдні країни біля Херсона
ЗСУ відкинули російські підрозділи.
Щодня ми розповідаємо про
драматичні події війни в Україні.
Як відомо, журналістам дуже важко говорити
про Росію та в ній.
Будь-кого, хто вживає
слово «війна», можуть покарати.
У таких напружених умовах Аксель Шторм
підготував свій сюжет у Москві.
Ура!
Натовп на Пушкінській площі в Москві,
вочевидь, зголоднів,
проте людям треба почекати.
Перш ніж скуштувати теплі бургери,
треба послухати й теплі слова.
Ми дуже раді, що ви прийшли.
Це подія, яка має стати сенсацією.
Росія вміє смажити і робити картоплю фрі -
таким має бути сигнал.
Щоб поширити це повідомлення,
в цьому закладі можна побачити
більше журналістів, ніж клієнтів.
До речі, мережа тепер називається
«Вкусно - и точка» («Смачно - і крапка»).
- Смакує, як раніше?
- Мені здається, що тут забагато солі.
Бізнесмен Александр Ґовор планує
знову відкрити 850 ресторанів мережі.
Життя має тривати, просто трохи інакше.
Здається, не має бути жодних сумнівів
щодо стану економіки.
А санкції вже починають діяти.
На полицях супермаркетів досі вдосталь продуктів,
але ціни сильно зросли.
З пенсією 20 000 рублів (приблизно 330 євро)
це досить відчутно.
Все подорожчало десь на 30%.
Раніше буханець хліба
коштував 36 рублів, сьогодні - 64.
Дороге життя, невизначене майбутнє -
з цим зіткнулися як прихильники,
так і противники «спецоперації».
Анастасія, студентка-стоматолог, говорить:
«У медичній сфері санкції дуже відчутні.
У нас закінчуються деякі матеріали.
Я це відчуваю щодня на роботі,
нам бракує інструментів і робочих матеріалів».
Що буде далі?
Від багатьох людей ми чуємо,
що вони живуть одним днем,
адже невідомо, що буде завтра.
Сьогодні в Берліні десятки тисяч велосипедистів
домовилися разом покрутити педалі
на демонстраційному велозаїзді столицею,
вимагаючи кращих умов для велосипедистів.
Перекрили багато доріг,
навіть центральну магістраль.
Ефір продовжить Норберт Кеніг з новинами спорту.
Я ж скажу лише - 1:1.
Саме так: великі плани, та мало результатів.
Останні робочі дні перед заслуженим
літнім відпочинком уявляли по-іншому.
Збірна Німеччина й у третій грі
не здобуває перемоги,
але й не програє: у Будапешті матч
завершився з рахунком 1:1.
Повернення в кола рекордсменів загальмувалося.
Німеччина вже вкотре грає в нічию.
Три очки за три гри - це не та мета,
яку ми собі поставили.
Ми планували більше.
Тож ми не змогли справдити наші сподіванки.
Команді не бракує самокритики
в коментарях до своєї гри проти Угорщини.
Сьогодні в Будапешті нам не вистачило
трохи більше легкості.
Єдиний гравець світового рівня -
36-річний Мануель Ноєр, найстарший у команді.
Найчастіше буває так, що з видатним воротарем
гра не вдається.
Попри те, що Йонас Гофманн зрівняв рахунок,
атака залишається слабким місцем команди.
Німеччина шукає центрального нападника.
Чинний чемпіон не втрачає позицій у «Формулі-1».
Макс Ферстаппен переміг у Баку, Азербайджан,
на 8-му етапі Чемпіонату світу цього сезону.
Чемпіон світу Макс Ферстаппен
у команді «Red Bull», 5-та перемога за сезон,
25-та - за кар'єру.
Його колега з команди, Серхіо Перес,
прорвався вперед на початку перегонів
проти Шарля Леклера і перегнав його.
Продумана стратегія допомагає Леклерові
знову вирватись на провідну позицію,
проте у 20-му раунді пілот «Феррарі»
відстає через пошкодження двигуна.
Для Себастьяна Феттеля це були
найкращі перегони в сезоні,
в яких він фінішував шостим.
Гадаю, тут переважає позитив,
адже в нас більше очок,
ніж ми поки що отримали разом за весь рік.
Тому цей результат для нас важливий.
1-ше й 2-ге місця посіли Ферстаппен і Перес,
3-тє - Джордж Рассел у «Мерседесі».
Триває зворотний відлік
до спортивного заходу «Finals».
За два тижні Берлін знову перетвориться на арену
для чемпіонату Німеччини з 14 видів спорту.
Відкриють змагання топзірки
з легкої атлетики й плавання,
всього буде присвоєно 190 титулів.
У ці довгі спортивні вихідні «ARD» і «ZDF»
транслюватимуть подію
у програмі понад 25 годин.
Дякую, Норберте.
Наостанок -  швидкий огляд прогнозу погоди.
На півночі та сході хмарна погода
чергуватиметься з дощами та грозами.
Зливи будуть і біля Альп.
В інших частинах країни -
приємна й сонячна погода
з поривчастим північно-західним вітром
і температурою 16-25°.
А далі погода буде ще кращою.
О 21:45 будуть новини
«heute journal» з Марієттою Сломкою.
Завтра в ефірі «heute» з Вами буде Яна Парайґіс.
Дякую, що були з нами.